We now want to introduce some
examples of random variables,
and we will start with
the simplest
conceivable random variable--
a random variable that takes
the values of 0 or 1, with
certain given probabilities.
Such a random variable
is called a
Bernoulli random variable.
And the distribution of this
random variable is determined
by this parameter p, which is
a given number that lies in
the interval between 0 and 1.
Using PMF notation, we have
the probability of 0 being
equal to 1 minus p and the
probability of taking the
value 1 equal to p.
If you wish to plot this
particular PMF, the plot is
rather simple.
It consists of two bars,
one at 0 and one at 1.
This one has a height
of p and this has a
height of 1 minus p.
Bernoulli random variables show
up whenever you're trying
to model a situation where
you run a trial.
And that trial can result in
two alternative outcomes,
either success or failure, or
heads versus tails, and so on.
Another situation where
Bernoulli random variables
show up is when we're making a
connection between events and
random variables.
Here's how this connection
is made.
We have our sample
space, omega.
And within that sample space,
we have a certain event, A.
And outside of the event A, of
course, we have the complement
of A.
Our random variable is defined
so that it takes a value of 1,
whenever the outcome of the
experiment lies in A. And it
takes a value of 0 whenever the
outcome of the experiment
lies outside the event A,
so that it lies in the
complement.
This random variable is called
the indicator random variable
of the event A. It is
equal to 1 if and
only if event A occurs.
And the PMF of that
random variable
can be found as follows.
This is PMF notation.
This is the equivalent
probabilistic notation.
This is the probability that
the random variable
takes a value 1.
Now the random variable takes
the value of 1 if and only if
event A occurs.
And so what we have is that
our random variable, the
indicator random variable, is
a Bernoulli random variable
with a parameter p equal to the
probability of the event
of interest.
Indicator random variables are
very useful because they allow
us to translate a manipulation
of events to a manipulation of
random variables.
And sometimes the algebra of
working with random variable
is easier than working with
events, as we will see in some
later examples.